Petrichor is the smell of dust after rain.
It’s a combination of plant oils, bacteria
and ozone. But this doesn’t tell the whole
story. Petrichor smells, well dusty. How does
the smell get from the ground to our noses?
A recent study from researchers at MIT suggests
an aerosol effect is a main cause of the smell
of dust after a light rain.
We all know it. On a summer day when the air
has been stale and hot for days and suddenly
a summer shower provides relief. When we venture
outside to greet the world anew, we’re met
with one of the most unique smells on the
planet. It’s a smell as old as time itself,
but it went without a name for a surprisingly
long time. Petrichor was coined by two scientists,
Isabel Joy Bear and R. G. Thomas of Australia's
Commonwealth Scientific and Industrial Research
Organization, in 1964. The word uses Greek
terms, Petra-meaning stone, and ichor, the
special substance that flows in the veins
of gods.
But the mechanism behind Petrichor was a bit
of a mystery until MIT scientists captured
slow motion images of falling water drops.
The videos revealed that rain drops trap air
bubbles. When they hit the ground, the bubbles
capture small molecules from the soil. These
molecules bubble up and release aerosols,
not unlike the bubbles in a glass of champagne.
Capturing this common occurrence took a little
while. The scientists performed over 600 experiments
dropping water on 28 different surfaces. 12
artificial surfaces and 16 soil samples. To
recreate the different types of rainfall,
light and heavy and everything in between,
they varied the height. The higher the drop,
the faster it fell. They found a Goldilocks
effect. The most aerosols were produced when
the porous surface wasn’t too wet or too
dry and when the rain wasn’t too fast or
too slow. If the rain falls too fast, there’s
not enough time for the bubbles to form. So
that’s how the smell gets in the air, but
what is the smell made up of?
Previous studies suggest that the smell comes
from oil given off by plants during dry periods
that falls on top clay and dirt.
Speaking of dirt, another part of petrichor
comes from bacteria from the genus ACT TIN
O MY SEAT TEES actinomycetes. The same bacteria
that are responsible for a recent break in
antibiotics. When these bacteria die, they
release an organic compound called Geosmin,
which comes from the greek “earth smell”.
This is the damp, musty, strong well, earthy
smell after a storm. Human noses are extremely
sensitive to the compound, we sniff it out
it just 5 parts per TRILLION. It’s a harmless
chemical, while we love it outside, it can
reduce the quality of drinking water and wine.
The smell of storms comes from ozone. A word
which also has it’s roots in greek for “smell”.
Ozone is an alternative form of oxygen. While
ground level Ozone is an icky, harmful smog,
atmospheric Ozone helps block some of the
sun’s most damaging rays. Storm-related
ozone is created when an electrical charge
splits atmospheric nitrogen and oxygen molecules
into separate atoms. A few chemical reactions
later, the oxygen reorganizes itself. Most
atmospheric oxygen is made up of two atoms.
the typical O2. Yet during a storm, the reorganized
oxygen forms O3. The O3 is pushed down from
the atmosphere by downdrafts, allowing us
to sniff this stormy scent.
Scientist still haven’t found a way to bottle
Petrichor. They’ve tried. How many candles
and laundry detergents have names like “spring
rain”. Most artificial scents haven’t
come close because Petrichor is so complex
and some compounds exist only in small traces
that can’t be detected by some machines.
I wish they’d hurry up though, I’m tired
of waiting.
So do you love the smell of rain? Let me know
in the comments below …